welcome to this video this will be a
short video to show him a game that I
recently came across and it was simply
too spectacular to to not to show it
okay so let's um go through the moves
it's a game played in in November this
year about a month ago in the World
Youth Championships under under 14 so we
have to having 13 year olds playing him
a white player some from the Ukraine
probable runs off never heard of him
and I must admit that I never heard of
the black player either que viven Kaden
drove from from the United States who at
the end won this tournament even so he's
the new world champion under 14 and yeah
to get an idea the white players rated
2230 or 1420 2220 and trophies rated
2312 but you can be sure that a junior
player coming from the ukraine as well
as a talent he's not not a bad player so
let's see what happened this was played
there near the end of the tournament and
both players were near the top of the
field so it was an important game we
have a Sicilian defense and were on saw
here goes for this c3 line which is a
sight line that it's not too bad quite
interesting as an alternative to the
main lines the idea is that after Knight
f6 the e4 pawn is not attacked at all
you can protect it if you want with
moves like Bishop d3
but it is not attacked due to this Queen
a for trick once off played Bishop b2
and now black cannot
take the pawn because he loses on the
night so Bishop b2 and now black just
continues to develop there are
alternatives this knight c6 movement
Hecht is a bit risky maybe but it's not
clear if the black player fell into this
this line without any preparation or he
willingly a.m. went into this because
now white can play a deform and again
offering this e4 pawn and yeah this
position black can take the pawn but
it's a very risky business he didn't do
it in the game but I want to show
briefly what happens on 94 d5 yeah
taking the night and black cannot really
move the knight as then this Queen a for
business would be on again so black must
play this check this is the only way to
not lose some material instantly the
Queen here controls the a Foursquare so
if white Janna would move the the King
for example then black can't really move
the knight and there's no check on a
form so Knight c3 this is the real idea
yeah black it takes takes yeah now you
cannot take here because after Bishop d2
both the Queen and the neither hanging
like therefore place Knight to e5 now it
takes here Queen takes with the check we
nee five castles yeah and white has
sacrificed a whole bunch of pawns to
pawns but he's got enormous compensation
and in a practical game black normally
doesn't manage to hold this kind of
position White has an enormous plastic
over here so this is a very risky line
for black which trophy avoided
he didn't take on reform
he played d5
which is certainly um yeah more more
solid choice but cannot be really what -
black intended with the with this
society and set up to play d65
so let's play well it's not a big deal
we 5 94 93 he had this position he
decided to get played in a very simple
fashion I think it would be interesting
to try um yeah move like for example
Bishop g4 in this position of course
it's tricky because of Queen b3 but it
would be more in the spirit of this
opening what he did is he took on C 3 D
takes e 3 and E 6 which is yeah of
course solid but it looks a bit passive
if you check this Bishop on c8 it's not
the most happy piece at the moment of
course it's not so bad - this piece um
has a future on a6 probably and in the
game it's no problem at all we see that
white played for C form yeah Black's
ideas to play against the c3 pawn the
possible idea would be something like
let's say V 695 and then rooks the eight
at the end putting pressure here and
maybe drop the Knight to c4 so black
plays on the Queen side in fact in the
game we see that White Castle
Bishop e7 and now white played C form so
he didn't really want to have a position
with the c3 weakness he rather prefers
to have um a somewhat weak d4 pawn so um
this is the transformation now black
took what captured on C form and now
like it tends to play b6 we can see that
after root B 1 which is a typical move
in this kind of structure putting
pressure on line b7 and also intending
maybe rook b3 at the later stage not in
the next
- moves as 95 would follow but it can be
an idea to use the rookie on the
half-open file and maybe swing it over
to the kingside so be six so intending
to get the bishop than the long diagonal
d5 yeah white plays it very directly I
don't think this is a good move really
but it's it's sharp I'm sorry nine a
five the answer and now the bishop is
hanging and of course he didn't overlook
this it's um the normal move 95 um he
well I play um put his hope Center on to
this mover d6 yeah this is interesting
but maybe I'm ultimately not not so
great let's see what happens he took on
d6 in fact here um black also could take
on c4 which is maybe the easier choice
she looked at this black has got an
extra pair up on the only problem is
that he's got his two pieces and in this
diagonal so Queen d3 is a slight issue
if black now would move the bishop then
there's some we should be three movement
is some that's a really strong diagonal
so I'm some it's quite tricky look has
the move Bishop h6 though and I don't
really see what white I can do to to
take him to take any advantage of this
this pin here this this pin I think
black is simply fine but it's hard to
hard to play over the board to make this
choice he took on d6 and then capture on
c4 which is not not bad really you can
you can do it the other continuation was
just a bit simpler I think yeah now
white won't look before there may be
possible improvements here but I don't
want to spend too much time on
on each movie because it's really mostly
about one critical position you should
basics protecting the night and now
taking this bishop so we have a ya mini
repetition of moves um but but now black
took on d6 playing for four win
obviously black now has two extra points
and can easily add for example sacrifice
in exchange at some point to continue
the game as to pawn some uh nice
compensation yeah here white um played
group to you one it was attacked and
like when Bishop c6 using the bishop on
the long diagonal yeah in fact if you if
you would would check this position with
a computer but simply tell you okay
black it's two pawns up and has no
problems at all this is the the computer
valuation but if you look at the the
position in on the board and imagine
that you would play this with black then
you know maybe are getting a little bit
scared white has got a very good night
on e5 he's got ideas to swing the rook
over getting into the attack and the
bishop on c1 okay it's not attacking
anything at the moment but it is always
ready to sacrifice itself in case h6 is
played what would sacrifice or it can be
used on the long diagonal probably so
this is not so easy at all you can
easily get swindled in this position the
computer of course would win this easily
with black but it's not easy for a human
okay at your plate Knight f5 which is in
fact a very human move to overprotect h6
and use the night for defensive purposes
and white now gets into position to play
Bishop g5 and
put something on f6 we see this visa
soon a five attacking the rook and it
swung over to 2f form probably intending
to sacrifice itself at some point
against this defending Knight rook c8
and Bishop a3 rook e8 we should be too
back so this this had a concrete idea
this Bishop a3 to be to okay so take a
look at this position now black plate
rook to c2 very natural attacking the
bishop and yeah we're nearing the the
absolutely critical position in the game
and also the position where like I'm
needed to find a really outstanding move
here white plate yeah somewhat shocking
move Bishop to f6 and now I'm if you
don't know the game which probably is
the case for most of you if you don't
know the game then strongly advise to to
stop this video and take a look at to
this position why this just attacked the
Queen with Bishop f6 of course the
bishop can be taken and yeah I advise
you to take a look at this and and
calculate a bit various variations so um
I'll be silent for a couple of seconds
to give you the chance to to stop the
video and I'll continue after that okay
I'm back now and we'll continue with the
analysis it's very good a good training
for calculation skills to calculate this
position and unless you're really
brilliant tactician
I guess you played a losing move now for
black because in this position black has
exactly one move that wins the game and
this is the only move that does not lose
all other moves lose instantly and the
move that black played is I don't show
it I first show the move that lose he
okay let's start with some simple ones
let's say Queens to seven attacking the
rook and attending c1 then white can
simply capture the knight on f5 as he
takes F rook takes the ADEs checkmate
so after this it's over black cannot
take and white has very strong attack
with the Queen g5 coming or night h6
coming all kinds of attacks
Quincy 8 some covering of the rook so
that rook takes f5 is not not the best
move but White has a very strong
alternative and this is night to h6
which is really strong and the move you
can can easily easily overlook if black
would take it with a knight then you've
got Queen to g5 and you threaten mate
now from black returns to cover it then
you take and here black has no time to
capture on f5 because of Queen g7 made
his loss though g6 Queen h6 is also mate
and yeah of course this is also made
next move or maybe you can
yeah it's made next move freely Knight
h6 is exceptionally strong thumb if
black takes with the pawn then white
also went with the move Queen to g4
check King here and rook takes a5 and
black again losses when g7 mate as
threatened anthem there's no way to
prevent it really or to avoid immediate
loss this you can you can try but the
again completely completely over so
white has really some some strong
attacking potential what would happen if
black would go to to h8 then white can
win with the capture and this one this
is one mate and this is the number mate
so a bunch of nice meeting attacks so
you cannot move the Queen obviously
so yeah what what should like do okay
let's check if you take the bishop
simply then white would take on f5
strong move
he takes F of course white was
threatening Knight f6 Knight H takes all
kinds of text yeah idea I'm white can
simply take on the eight Queen takes
Knight takes check King f8 Queen h6
check this is important because the
Queen now covers c1 so there's not Roxy
1 checkmate black recaptures and yeah
white is winning here you can play
something like h4 and you grab the H
pawn and run with the edge pawn so why
does quicker then in black on the Queen
side despite the fact that you've got a
queen against two pieces but the H pawn
is exceptionally strong
so if black cannot take the bishop and
cannot move the Queen here what what he
sees what is he supposed to play in fact
as mentioned there's only only one move
and this move was actually found by the
black player always keep in mind that
he's 13 years old he played the stunning
move rook to e2 leaving the Queen on
free
and leaving the rukon free yeah so it
also threatens checkmate of course so
white um doesn't really have a choice II
he took the rook and then black played
Queen to c7 this is really the amazing
thing here that black can give up the
rook just like that and then played this
yeah this this can move Queen to c7
which takes the rook and threatens
checkmate so it's a double attack
basically that white cannot cover
he cannot both cover the rook on f4 and
cover the the checkmate threat so it's
it's really amazing what what it simply
has no movie and it's not a mate or a
direct attacker from the white side
which only consists of checks they're
always yeah silent moves there that
don't involve a check so and all those
moves simply need to own shag mates
let's say just for example this kind of
idea was was a problem but it's it's
simply checkmate in one move for two
moves
what can interpose but then it's made
for all those attacking ideas white
needs one preparation move and this this
is simply it does not get as this rook
is hanging and c1 is is threatened
yeah White has no move something like
this you take the rook and also Bishop
b2
then this rook is gone and without this
attacking rook on the fourth rank on a
form and whites attack simply lacks
punch and black hair just emerges with
these two extra pawns and no no direct
problems so this um this knockout rookie
to simply won the game but it's it's so
incredibly difficult to foresee I would
really like to know if he saw this in
advance or he stumbled onto this
nevertheless it's great that
he found the movement simply outstanding
um okay so let's continue
why took as much and Queen to c7 yeah he
tried and look after you form which
covers the mate s Quincy one now can be
answered with Ruby one
yeah but black can simply take yeah and
now white cannot recapture as then
there's made again so you simply got the
Rope back and in the process have
exchanged the important attacking rook
and white um yes simply ran out of steam
here
he of course tried to fight he played
Queen to g5 which still threatens the
knight to h6 so there's still some some
tricks to to look at but a black coat
blooded cold-blooded way played rook c8
and again threatened check mate with the
Queen
c1 so night h6 for example is simply
answered by um by King f8 and there's
there's nothing not even a sensible
check or something and here basically
get white is toast yes no moves he
played we should be true to to cover the
meeting square and now I'm a good really
good move again Queen to d8 threatening
yeah well asking the White Queen if you
want once to exchange itself but also
threatening checkmate on d1 so white um
doesn't have a choice really he gave
this cheque to avoid the Queen and the
Queen exchange King edge eight rock d2
and this was the last try attacking the
the Queen yeah if you want you can pause
the video again and have a quick look or
to watch should black play here
be silent for about five seconds
yeah Blackie I can finish the game and
team he did with Queen takes f6
yeah mopping up in style here if white
captures the Queen the nurse Rooke Siwon
made the big back rank and alternatively
Queen takes you simply simply take and
you have an extra piece at the end so I
think really this this rookie to move is
one of the most spectacular moves I've
seen in a long time
some grandmasters even sat and who were
present and at the at this tournament
that this rookie too was one of the most
spectacular moves that they that they
know one of the spectators particular
moves of all time yet certainly
certainly amazing to put the rukon pre
and then sort of play a double attack on
on the c1 squared the rook this is
really really outstanding yeah I think
one of the roofs of the year and I hope
you enjoyed it if you and if you really
found this move when I post the video
and you didn't get any help from from a
computer or something then my
congratulations to you but I must admit
that when I saw the game it was
presented on the ICC by Grandmaster
Benjamin I didn't know the game and when
he then he showed this move I was really
close falling off my chair alright so I
hope you enjoyed the video I'll be back
soon with new with new videos or play em
some tournament games over the weekend
maybe there's some interesting content
there yeah till then bye